Moderator: Okay, I have started the recording, and I'd like to confirm, again, are you comfortable if I record my screen and audio as we talk today?
P1: Yes, ma'am.
Moderator: And are you comfortable if we decide to use the recorded clip from our discussion today to share with our VA partners if we remove any information that can be used to identify you?
P1: Yes.
Moderator: Okay, perfect. So, before we jump into and look at the prototype, we have a few warm-up questions. So, first off, do you have a VA.gov account?
Moderator: Okay, and how often are you logging into VA.gov, and for what type of task?
P1: Every week… every couple of weeks, trying to see if they fixed my GI Bill stuff yet.
Moderator: Okay, that's helpful, just for context moving forward. So have you ever applied for the CHAMPA program?
P1: Yes.
Moderator: Okay is there anyone in your household who's currently enrolled in the program?
P1: Yes, ma'am.
Moderator: Okay, thank you. And did you fill out that application online, on paper, or over the phone?
P1: On paper, that was the only option that was available to me when we did it.
Moderator: Okay.
Moderator: And can you tell me your experience, what it was like, after you submitted the CHAMPA application?
P1: I know for the last one for my daughter, it took several months for them to finalize it.
Moderator: Hmm.
P1: Just because of the backlog, they were, like, 5 months backlogged when I did it.
Moderator: I see, I see. And then, was there anything that you had to mail or fax in, after you had submitted your application?
P1: No.
Moderator: Okay, so it was just that true backlog at the time. There was no additional request. Okay.
Moderator: So, let's say that you just submitted your CHAMPVA application on VA.gov. I know that you were only given the paper option, but let's say if you did it online, what would you expect to happen after you submitted your application?
P1: We'd probably hope for a confirmation email.
P1: And then just the waiting process.
P1: I noticed that with a lot of VA.gov stuff is that you don't get a confirmation email, so if you don't print out the confirmation and it pops up, you lose any record that you applied for it.
Moderator: Hmm, okay. So you just mentioned the email. How would you expect to be notified or find updates about your application?
P1: Probably go to VA.gov.
Moderator: Okay. Can you tell me a little bit more about that.
P1: Maybe check in the claims section?
P1: Probably.
Moderator: And how often would you be checking VA.gov or the claims section?
P1: Probably at least once a day. If I'm waiting for something to be processed.
Moderator: Okay. And what would you like to be notified about?
P1: Any changes to the… application.
Moderator: Okay, and I know you mentioned checking every day, but I'm curious, how soon do you expect to be notified, about any updates on your application?
P1: Probably as soon as it happens.
Moderator: Okay.
Moderator: Okay, well, thank you for going through some of those intro questions. So, now we're actually going to jump into the prototype. So, I am going to share a link with you in the chat.
P1: Okay.
Moderator: And then I'm going to drop in the password as well.
Moderator: So, which I would like you to open this link in your browser, and you're going to share your screen in Zoom. I can help you walk through how to share your screen, but I want to give you a moment to close any browser, windows, tabs, or applications that you may have running, and just silence notifications on your device so it doesn't interfere. So, let me know when, you have all that set up.
P1: There we go.
Moderator: Okay, perfect.
Moderator: Okay, so now that you have the prototype up, I'm gonna give you a couple of scenarios today, and have you give me feedback as you navigate through the prototype. So, on each page, I'm gonna have you please share what you were thinking out loud so we can hear your honest opinion. Again, we all want to improve these tools, and we're not testing your ability in any way. So, do you have any questions before we get started?
P1: No, ma'am.
Moderator: Okay? So, for this first scenario, I would like you to imagine that you just submitted a CHAMPVA application recently for two family members, Jane and John Doe Jr, and you want to find out what is happening with your application. So, you log in to VA.gov, and this upcoming screen is the first thing that you see. I want you to go ahead and click continue.
P1: Yep, that is very nice. Right there, tell me what I need.
Moderator: Perfect. So, if you wanted to find out what is happening with your CHAMPVA application, can you show me what you would do next? I want you to take a moment to review the page, think out loud as you go, but don't click on anything yet, so we can get your feedback on the page before you move on. Also, just want to note that this page may look different than what you have seen before on VA.gov.
P1: Okay. Well, I definitely clicked… probably clicked check status details. For both of them. Do you want me to click them? I'm sorry.
Moderator: Oh, so go ahead and just explore the full page for me.
P1: Okay, oh, okay, yeah.
P1: This is all nice having all this right here. I feel like I have to dig through so much through VA.gov to find what I'm looking for.
P1: But having this right here all in one thing is very, very helpful.
Moderator: Nice. So, one of the things that you said in the beginning is that you would check your status details, you would actually look at both cards that were there. I'm curious, what do you think would happen if you clicked the link?
P1: Probably open up to… Same information, it's more detailed. Well, more… spread out more? Like, they're not gonna add anything, because it's just initial review.
P1: But maybe bragging about the same thing. Maybe just with overview of all 5 steps.
Moderator: I see. Okay, so we'll come back to that a little bit more. So, for now, I want you to zoom out and just tell me about, is this section what you, where you expected to find your application?
P1: -Oh.
P1: Maybe? What?
P1: I don't know, to be honest.
P1: Because… Oh… I mean, claims applications, that would be where I would look to find it, yes.
Moderator: Okay, so at first you said maybe, so can you tell me a little bit more.
P1: I… I noticed this right here.
Moderator: Oh, I see, okay.
P1: That caught my eye. I was like, oh, yeah.
P1: I'm not trying to see anything else that would... This is different than what I'm used to, so that threw me… threw me to…
Moderator: Okay, so what did you expect to be in this section versus what do you see in the section now?
P1: Normally, the claims…
P1: Like, this is a whole new section for me. Does this even exist on VA.gov? Because they only have, like… It does?
Moderator: So this is a prototype in a demo.
P1: Well, I understand this is a prototype. But I don't even have anything to base this off of, because I'm used to the claims for disability claims only.
P1: Like, I'm not used to having all of this on one page. That's why I feel like I sound like I'm bouncing around so much.
P1: Like, normally to get all this, I have to go to, like, 4 or 5 different pages to find.
Moderator: Okay. So, as we're also exploring MyVA right now, before we move on, I want you to scroll down to the section called Forms.
P1: Okay.
Moderator: And I'm curious, what would you expect to find in this section?
P1: In the in-progress form, maybe a list of most common forms? Like, the application for disability benefits, the CHAMPVA Education Form, maybe stuff that people click on a lot of the time.
P1: Because that's another issue, is trying to find the correct form to fill out.
Moderator: Okay, so if what I just heard, you were looking for a list of forms, like, the type of forms that you would fill out.
P1: Yes.
Moderator: Okay, if you could go ahead and click on the completed forms for me. I am curious about what you see there, and what you expect to see here.
P1: That would be very helpful, having all my completed forms right there.
P1: So I could know… maybe, confirmation number?
P1: So when I call, I can ask about it? If I needed to call?
P1: It said if you have questions.
P1: So we set, like, a confirmation number so they can pull up that form instead of… especially just the more you do in the VA, the more forms you fill out. I got a gazillion different forms that I have filled out over the years.
Moderator: I definitely understand that. So, between these two sections, I guess in your own words, how would you describe what the claims and application status section is for versus what the form section is for?
P1: Claims and status would be stuff that I have open.
P1: maybe not tied much to the… as to the form as to what I'm trying to do. I see one's ChampVA and one's Specialty Adapted Housing.
P1: You can just click on one I'm trying to think of which claim I'm trying to figure out, and then down here would be a list of everything I've filled out at some points. Again, I need to go back and look at maybe what I put in an application or something?
P1: Just, like, more like a FYI in case I need to look up something 5 years later.
Moderator: Okay. No, that's really helpful, just knowledge and context. I am quickly curious about, like, what are your thoughts on the names of these sections?
P1: They are… I'd say they're perfect. They're exactly… they tell me what I need, and they're divided up where I can find out what's going on.
Moderator: Okay, so we're gonna go ahead and move on, and so I know you've mentioned this already, but now that you've seen both sections, what would you do next?
P1: Probably click on the check status details and see what it says in there.
Moderator: Okay, so let's go ahead and check status details.
P1: Okay, so that one… that was a broken link. Okay.
P1: Yeah, that, that, Is it… what's,
P1: Which… oh, that's a nice help one, being able to upload files as you need them.
P1: Files received… yep, that is good, so I can see what I've already submitted.
P1: And then other ways you can send them if you want to do it the old-fashioned way.
P1: But this looks like an overview… yep, that's what I was talking about, those different steps.
P1: And an overview of the steps. That's what I meant earlier.
P1: And then, yep, what you need to do… yeah, it doesn't update the mail, of course.
P1: this is where I was talking about there's an update, like, maybe an email?
Moderator: Hmm.
P1: You know, a letter's gonna take, you know, 2-3 weeks to reach to you by the time it gets printed and mailed and processed through the system and delivered. That's, you know, 2 or 3 weeks.
P1: Oh me sitting there going, well, I wonder if they're doing anything yet. Which I know a lot of veterans do, prefer mail, but I'm like, let's get it done as fast as humanly possible.
Moderator: Efficiency, I definitely understand.
Moderator: So, I know that you've kind of gone through each of the tabs, but, could you tell me a little bit more about what you've seen on each of these pages, and can you tell me what you've learned about your application?
P1: Okay, so the application, it tells me where it is, gives me an update, lets me know if they're looking for anything.
P1: Which, you may be, since I'm checking every day, I would see that and know I need to probably…Probably for this application, upload a birth certificate or something.
P1: The, ability to select who it's for is also very helpful.
Moderator: Hmm.
P1: Because that helps keep everything situated, because I know when I first became eligible for CHAMPVA, I had 6 people? 5 or 6 people to do, so there was a… that was a… quite a stack of papers I had faxed in.
Moderator: I see, so…
Moderator: I am curious, can you tell me about what that process was like, applying for everybody when you were CHAMPVA eligible?
P1: I said, because I had to fill out the form for everybody, then I had to fill out the secondary insurance form for everybody.
P1: And then get their social, and their birth certificate, and marriage certificate for my wife.
P1: And there was 5 of them, so that's… Like, 4 or 5 sheets times 4 people each.
Moderator: Hmm.
P1: That was a several-hour process of getting everything together.
Moderator: Yeah.
Moderator: Well, thank you for providing a little bit of
your experience in the past as well. So, coming back to the prototype really quickly, now that you've kind of reviewed the pages, you saw where your application is at, what do you think will happen next?
P1: You know, sit there till…
P1: Somebody manually reviews it, is my guess, and then either…
P1: So, this is… I think this was in step 1… Yeah.
P1: This is always a fun part.
P1: But you can go to that, it'll go through, which is hopefully, at this point, I've provided everything, so you can go straight into step 3.
P1: And Champ VA is usually pretty easy, once you actually get to it, if you provide everything, and then they approve it.
P1: And… move on.
P1: And then you just wait 3 weeks for the package to get there.
Moderator: Okay.
Moderator: And we'll come back and talk a little bit more about the overview tab in a minute, but thank you for kind of that walkthrough. So, you had mentioned this earlier, you were talking about uploading, let's say, a birth certificate. So, I'm going to actually have you pretend that you want to submit an updated marriage certificate for Jane Doe. What would you do in order for that?
P1: Go to Files, select Jane Doe, and then…
P1: Probably drag the file over, if that's an option.
Moderator: Yep, so go ahead and click that, click in the file upload box, and we'll pretend that you brought a file from your device, but just don't click submit yet.
P1: Okay… oh, cool!
P1: Yep, document… marriage certificate, And then… We'll hit submit for review.
Moderator: Okay, we'll pause on that real fast. So, how was that process for you? Was it what you expected?
P1: Yes, that's exactly what I would expect to happen.
Moderator: Can you walk me through the process that you went through, or the parts of it, and just explain to me in a little bit more detail?
P1: I'm… what do you mean, I'm sorry?
Moderator: Sorry, I was just… I'm curious, how was that process for you?
P1: was very simple and straightforward. I selected who I needed.
P1: Uploaded the document, told the system what document, so the reviewer can know what it's for.
P1: And then just would submit it.
Moderator: Okay, so I'm gonna go ahead and have you, continue with submitting the file now.
P1: Okay.
P1: Yep, receive the file. And then…
P1: I would… yeah, probably go here. That's nice, having it right there, and then you can just see that it was submitted and confirmed that it was received.
Moderator: Okay, thank you for going through that scenario for us. So, you'd walked through this a moment ago, but can you quickly go back to the overview tab for me, and can you, in your own words, kind of explain what is happening in each of the steps?
P1: Okay, so this one is telling me when I applied for it, and that they received it, and they will get to it
P1: When it gets into somebody's queue.
P1: This one is where somebody will be assigned to it.
P1: And…
P1: We'll look and see if I need any more information submitted. And then I can go there to see…
P1: I'm assuming that at some point, when we get to this step, it's gonna say that it's missing documents, or something similar, and I can go here and find out what they actually need.
P1: And submit those.
P1: And then, once we get here, it'll say we've received everything, and they're just going over.
P1: Everything to make sure that they have a… everything they needed.
P1: Which hopefully they don't, because we got out of step 2.
P1: And then step 4 will tell me they've either
P1: I'm assuming he's gonna tell me they made a decision, and… Hmm… Awesome, Mel, so that,
P1: I can go to the status page to see what's actually decided if it doesn't tell me right there.
P1: And then letting me know I'll receive an official decision letter.
Moderator: Okay, so thank you for walking through all of those steps, kind of just explaining to us how they resonate with you and what they mean to you. So, that is the end of our first scenario, so we're going to go on to the next one, and I'm going to have you scroll all the way down to the bottom of the screen, and there you're going to click the button that says Proceed to the next scenario.
Moderator: So here, let's say a week has passed, and you want to find out what has happened with your Triumph application. You log in to VA.gov, and this upcoming screen is the first thing that you see. So I want you to go ahead and click Continue.
Moderator: So, now I want you to take a look at the page and tell me what do you see?
P1: It says, they are missing something for the CHAMPVA application.
Moderator: So what do you feel like has happened with your application, then?
P1: Somebody has looked at it and realized that they are missing something.
Moderator: Okay, so what would you do next, then?
P1: I would click Check Status Details.
Moderator: Okay, so go ahead and click the check status details then.
P1: Okay.
Moderator: So, now I want you to take a look at this page, and again, in your own words, tell me what has happened to your application.
P1: It has been updated to say that they need something, which…
P1: Looks like it's the copy of the birth certificate, which…
P1: I'm very impressed that I forgot that.
P1: Noon, but obviously I would go… Click here…
Moderator: Okay, we'll hold off on that for now.
P1: That's why I was… that's why I was hesitating.
Moderator: Yeah, I appreciate the pause. So, go ahead and keep looking at the page.
P1: Okay.
Moderator: And tell me what else that you see.
P1: They made a decision on something… else.
P1: So they made a decision on that, that's… yep, mail acceptance letter should run simultaneously, so she is good, I… that's even more impressive, but I remember her stuff and forgot his.
P1: That?
P1: Interesting. That kind of just… Throws you for a loop right there.
P1: Because you don't really know… Well, application… Hmm.
P1: Interesting, because these are, like.
P1: Oh, because you're doing a… okay, application for multiple people, not an application for each person.
P1: Okay.
P1: So that's also weird that they made a decision on part of it, on part of your application. Okay, well, that makes sense.
P1: So…
P1: Open the request for membership. Okay,
P1: Okay, so we're… let me… let's come back, let me come back to you guys, sorry.
Moderator: No, no, no, it… that's what this part was for, for you to explore, help us understand, does this make sense? So, I saw at the bottom that…
Moderator: you were kind of looking at Jane's application, and then we're going back up, so can you just tell me what you were seeing, or what you were thinking through?
P1: It threw, it caught me off guard. I didn't realize that, they were both part of one application.
P1: And I guess I do appreciate the fact that they enrolled her.
P1: And moved on, instead of holding up both of them for the one… one person.
Moderator: Hmm.
P1: Because it threw me, because I saw this, and then down here, I was like, well, what's this go to? And then I was like, oh, okay, it's for both of them.
P1: Okay.
Moderator: So, really quickly, can you tell me what step the application is on, and does that make sense to you?
P1: It does, it makes, step 2, they're still looking for more information before they can…
P1: Just a second, I'm so sorry.
Moderator: Oh, no, you were fine.
P1: Hey, what's up?
P1: Yes, ma'am.
P1: Okay.
P1: Sorry, that was my wife, I wouldn't have answered for anybody else.
Moderator: No, you were okay. Are you okay to continue?
P1: I am.
Moderator: Okay.
P1: Okay, yep, step two, because we're still trying to get, John Doe Jr.'s information.
Moderator: So, I know you kind of said this out loud, but just to clarify, can you tell me what has happened with Jane's application, as well as what has happened with John Joe Jr.'s application?
P1: Jane's part of the application has been approved, and they are mailing all her, her CHAMPVA card to her.
P1: And then John Jr, they need his birth certificate.
Moderator: Okay, so…
P1: What? They want me to upload.
Moderator: Okay, so what would you do next, then?
P1: Probably review request.
Moderator: Okay, so you can go ahead and click that link.
P1: Oh, blah blah blah blah blah blah, okay.
Moderator: Yep, so go ahead and review this page, tell me what you see, and what is this request for?
P1: Yeah, and he has his birth certificate.
P1: They have mailed a letter also requesting it, just in case I'm not checking every day like a hyponder, or a crazy person.
P1: And then, next steps, what I need to do, blah blah blah…
P1: Yep, review it, and then move on to step 3, and then here's where I can upload it.
Moderator: Okay, so now that you've gotten to this part, what would you do next, then?
P1: Would attach the file in that box?
Moderator: So go ahead and click the file upload, and again, we'll pretend like you're bringing in a file from your device, but don't click the submit button yet.
P1: It is uploaded, it does not give me an option, but they already are looking for it, so they know what it's gonna be.
Moderator: Okay, so can you tell me a little bit more about this experience? Is this what you expected to happen?
P1: Yes?
P1: Except for the, the option to select a drop-down, but that's already implied because it's asking for upload copy of birth certificate.
Moderator: I see, okay. So you kind of got ahead for me, but I was gonna ask, you know, how was this experience compared to uploading the marriage certificate?
P1: It was about the same.
P1: A little bit streamlined, because it's…
P1: I'm looking for something specific, the marriage certificate was just me uploading the file to go with the application.
Moderator: Hmm… Okay.
Moderator: That's helpful. So, I'm gonna have you go ahead and continue with submitting the file.
P1: There it is the feedback.
Moderator: Yup, so take a look at this page and tell me what you see.
P1: Nope.
P1: It went… it went straight to information review.
P1: Which… that's a new one.
P1: We don't need to… and there's a version we submitted.
P1: I'm guessing it's assuming, because it went automatically because I uploaded what it was looking for. That's kind of nice.
P1: That saves a day or two.
Moderator: Is that what you expected to happen?
P1: No, it's not. Normally, at least in my experience, it's been you upload the information, then it sits there until somebody actually reviews it.
P1: And verifies that it's there.
P1: And then they review it, so that's saving a…
P1: I don't know if that actually saves a step on the back, and I don't know the process enough, but… makes me feel happy!
Moderator: And that is our goal. So, okay. Well, that is the end of our second scenario. So, to go to the last scenario, I'm gonna have you scroll all the way down to the bottom and click to proceed to the next scenario.
P1: Okay.
Moderator: Okay, so now another week has passed since you uploaded the requested document. You want to check on the status of your transfer application again, so you've logged back into VA.gov, and this upcoming screen is the first thing you see. So I'm going to have you go ahead and click continue.
Moderator: So now I want you to take a look at this page and tell me what you see. What do you think has happened with your application?
P1: I would guess it's been closed.
P1: And also wonder why I've requested a new dependent.
P1: But I would definitely scroll… down to 6…
P1: Well, look and see if there's anything… oh…
P1: There. Probably go here, since that, Champ VA one has disappeared.
Moderator: Okay, so why do you think, your CHAMP VA application has disappeared, or why don't you think it's on the screen?
P1: My guess…
P1: is… it was approved and closed, because it was looking for that one thing, and I uploaded it.
P1: And they… Saw it and said, okay, we're good, approve him. Enrolled, John Jr. and CHAMPVA.
Moderator: Okay, and I am also curious, I noticed that you scrolled down, was there anything that you were looking for in particular?
P1: I was looking to see, there was, like,
P1: Like, anything that's talking about that, maybe a completed claims section or something.
Moderator: Can you tell me a little bit more about what you mean by that?
P1: Like, if there was somewhere where, instead of, the status here, like, if… somewhere where it's… I had said,
P1: The CHAMPVA application was closed.
P1: Like, just anything, because it wasn't… because it was here, and then it wasn't.
Moderator: Okay.
P1: I was just scrolling down to see if it had popped up anywhere else.
Moderator: Mmm.
P1: No, this is more active stuff, not… Stuff that's already done.
Moderator: I see. So, if… if what I'm hearing you say is that those two car… or what you're seeing under the claims and application status, those fill as if they are the active.
P1: Yes.
Moderator: Active claims or active applications.
P1: It's usually, like, claims… Archived claims area for something that I haven't completed.
Moderator: Okay, so you had hovered over the track claims, decision reviews, and applications a moment ago, so what would you expect to see if you clicked that?
P1: prob… The CHAMPVA saying that it's probably reached step 5 of 5, decision…
P1: Finalized, or whatever it is, decision received.
P1: Can't think of the right word at the moment, but yeah, basically saying that it's closed, the claim is closed.
Moderator: Hmm, okay. So, I'm gonna have you go ahead and click on that link.
Moderator: So, again, I want you to take some time to review this page and to think out loud.
P1: Yeah, and then I would go… Hit the closed…
P1: have, and expect to see it there, telling me that it's done, and that John Jr. has been enrolled in CHAMPVA.
P1: Yeah, and then clutters, that's all nice, having all that right there. Always look at the dig for the letters.
P1: The app makes it easy, though, but the website is not the friendliest for printing letters.
Moderator: Okay, so go ahead and see if you can find his, find your Champ VA card.
P1: The card or the claim?
Moderator: Oh.
Moderator: Well, the application for CHAMPVA, I guess.
P1: Yep, application… decided, and then I would click on Check Status Details to see what it says.
Moderator: Okay, so overall, before we click that link, how does this compare to what you expected to find?
P1: That's what I expected to find.
P1: It is nice having all that in progress and all right there.
P1: I feel like I have to keep saying this, but I feel like I always have to dig through it to find anything on CHAMPVA.
P1: This is a lot nicer user interface than I'm used to.
Moderator: Well, that is good feedback for some of our teams to hear as well. Okay, so you mentioned that you would click the check status details, so go ahead and click continue to move forward.
P1: Yep. So…
Moderator: Take a look at this page and tell me what you see.
P1: See, status application and made a decision… then there's the breakdown of the decisions, the Jane Doe is enrolled, John Doe is not eligible.
P1: And we have mailed John a letter explaining why they're not eligible for CHAMPVA benefits. Hmm.
P1: And that is where we wait for the letter, which I know they have to do.
P1: the letter…
P1: Because they can't talk about it over the phone, which has always been infuriating to me, because it only takes a couple weeks to get there, but that's just…
P1: He said, we have to figure out what happened.
P1: But let me know what's going on so I know how to prepare next.
P1: Let's see what's going on.
Moderator: So, I know you mentioned this, but I'm just, again, for the record, what would you… what is the status of Jane's application versus John Joe Jr.'s?
P1: Jane Doe has been enrolled, and John Jr. has not been enrolled for some reason.
Moderator: Yeah, and you mentioned potentially calling in the past. Overall, what would you do next, if anything?
P1: I would probably call anyway and see if they could tell me what happened.
P1: Because it's weird… I mean, I'm assuming that it's my biological son that was just born, or a son that I just got eligible for CHAMP VA for, which is why I'm enrolling both of them at the same time.
Moderator: And you would… oh, I'm sorry, go ahead.
P1: No, I said this, I'd call and find out what's going on.
Moderator: And you mentioned some of your experiences in the past where you have called, but you couldn't get some of the information on the phone. Can you tell me a little bit more about that experience?
P1: Probably should clarify that that's more for, like, disability claims. They can't tell you what it says, you have to wait for the official letter. CHAMPVA is usually better about being able to talk about what's going on. I should have clarified that better.
P1: A few different areas.
Moderator: Okay. Well, no, it's still helpful feedback, so thank you for clarifying that and providing a little bit more information.
Moderator: Okay, so that is the end of our scenarios for today, so you can go ahead and stop sharing your screen, and then I'll ask you a few more questions before we finish up.
P1: Okay.
P1: Stop sharing, there we go.
Moderator: Okay, perfect. So, can you tell me about your overall impression of this prototype?
P1: I liked it a lot, it was very helpful.
P1: I've never… that's been a… I was a good VA.gov experience.
Moderator: What were some of the things that you liked about it?
P1: How everything was right where I… where, where I could see it easy.
P1: That was something that I feel like I usually struggle with.
P1: Yeah, that's about it, sorry.
Moderator: No, no, no, it's helpful. So, I know we… I had asked you about your past experience applying, but how would you say that this comp… How would you compare this post-application experience? You just walked through to your previous experience after applying for CHAMPA?
P1: I would have loved to do, this experience as opposed to those forms, especially because I have to fill out the same form six times, because it's only for one person.
P1: That was very nice.
Moderator: Okay, thank you. So, was there anything that was confusing or unexpected in this prototype?
P1: Not really. Not once I thought about it, it made sense.
Moderator: What were the areas that you felt like you had to think a little bit more about?
P1: probably that, part before I realized that it was one application for two people.
P1: And it had Jane Doe approved, and then step two of… Step 2 of 4?
P1: That's what caught me off guard. I was like, what are we talking about? And then I realized what it was.
Moderator: Okay, so the… so you were saying, first off, that it was… there were two people on this application, but your past experience is that each person had their own individual application.
P1: Yes, so that's what I was going off of, and… Okay.
Moderator: Okay, and then can you tell me a little bit more about the step 2 out of 4?
P1: Just having it… so she said enrolled, and then step 2 out of 4, and I wasn't sure what claim that was going with at first.
Moderator: Okay.
Moderator: And were you… just for my clarification, when you're saying claim, or what does claim mean to you versus application mean?
P1: I use claim as a catch-all for submitting VA stuff. It needs to be a CHAMPVA application.
P1: Okay. Specifically. Okay.
Moderator: No, I just wanted to make sure I understood. Okay, thank you for that. So for this next section, I'm going to read through 3 statements, and I would like you to rate how much you agree or disagree with each one on a scale of 1 to 5, where 1 means, like, strongly disagree, and 5 means strongly agree.
Moderator: So, I thought the prototype was easy to use.
P1: Strongly agree.
Moderator: Could you give me a number?
P1: Oh.
Moderator: 1 to 5.
P1: Do the scale again, I'm sorry, is it 5 strongly agree?
Moderator: Yeah, 5 is strongly agree, and 1 means strongly.
P1: the highest.
Moderator: Okay, perfect, thank you. I felt confident I understood what was happening with each person's application.
P1: 5.
Moderator: And the last one, I knew where to look to find any updates about my application.
P1: Five.
Moderator: Okay, thank you. So overall, if you could wave, like, a magic wand and change anything about the prototype or your overall experience after you submit an application for CHAMPVA,
Moderator: What would it be?
P1: Nothing, actually. That had everything that I would want. That would negate the thing for an email, too, if it popped right into a pending claim section.
Moderator: Can you tell me a little bit more about what you meant by that?
P1: Well, I sent an email to confirm, but…
Moderator: Oh, yeah.
P1: That was already had the confirmation there.
P1: Maybe just an email,
P1: when it went to, for John Doe Jr, when it wanted a birth certificate, I'm assuming no email went out.
P1: So, if they, even just saying that there's been a change, please go review, because a letter will take 2 weeks to get there.
P1: So that's 2 weeks where I could have been uploading the birth certificate.
Moderator: I see. Okay, so one of the main things that we could do to improve is providing email notifications.
P1: Yes.
Moderator: Okay.
Moderator: Okay, so do you, any of the observers, do any of you have any questions?
Rory: Nope, nothing from me, thank you.
Moderator: Okay Perfect. And then, so do you have any questions for me?
P1: No, thank you so much for this opportunity.
Moderator: Okay, thank you. So, I do want to circle back and reconfirm that you are comfortable. If we were to share a video clip in the session with our VA partners. Again, just a reminder, we will remove all information that could be used to identify you. Before sharing it, we'll only give the videos to our VA partners, and with the purpose of improving VA.gov and our other digital experiences.
P1: Yes, ma'am.
Moderator: Okay, perfect.
Moderator: And is there any part of our discussion you would not want to be shared in a video clip?
P1: Nope.
Moderator: Okay.
P1: I'm comfortable with everything being shared.
Moderator: Okay, thank you. So, well, with that, we really do appreciate you taking the time to share your thoughts with us today. Your feedback has been incredibly helpful for us as we continue to work on the site and VA.gov and make sure it really works for veterans and their families. Lastly, Perigean will be sending you a thank you note with a little blurb that you can pass along to other veterans and family members that you may know to provide them with a chance to participate in future studies as well.
Moderator: So, with that, thank you so, so much. Really appreciate it, and I hope you enjoy the rest of your day.
P1: Thank you, you too.
Moderator: Okay, thank you, have a good one.
P1: You too, bye.